Mà 2 mấy tặn thứ 2 và bỏ phíau đầu tiên của cột tổng tuyên cửa dân chủ đã đảng năm
hành nghiệm khương trang làm tạm miên mà đã chính thứ khác lại.
Bỏ phíau bắt đầu tủ lúc sống dự sáng thiêu dựa niềm phương và kết thúc vào lông người sống dựa
cùng ngày, tại các đi bỏ phíau chi thuần của công tắc tiêm phíau đất hiện hành cải trở
với tổng cộng một chăm ba mi chiến đình viên của các phay đoàn quan sát bầu cử
của tế, và đại diện cộng đồng ngoại sào tham gia sáng sáng,
với kiểm đêm bao gồm cả phíau bầu trực tiến và phíau bầu sống cho các cái trong hại việc thượng viện và các nghĩ việc cấp băng cấp bồng.
Cô tổng tuyên cửa miên mà nè mài nghiên không chăm lắm được tổng trước theo ba dựa.
2 vòng bỏ phíau tiếp theo dân sẽ xin xa và người bị mô tham mô.
Và 2 mạng tham mô nè mài nghiên không chăm mì sống.
Cô bầu cửa khoảng năm nghiên cứ biến đúng năm ngày bày đảng phay chiến trị.
Cô hơn 2 mất nghiên năm trong diện bỏ phíau chiến tặn của,
thì khoảng quý cùng sẽ đứa công bố xác hi ngoan tất cả các cơ đàn.
Khi bầu cử này đừng đánh xá đã đặc biệt ở vinh người dân miên mà,
bởi đây là lần đầu tiên người dân nước này đi bỏ phíau kể từ cuộc đạo chính hồi tháng 2 năm hành không chá miếm mốt.